I am just getting back from the Apple
event and I had such an awesome time and
thank you guys so much for subscribing I
also just hit six million subscribers so
this has been a really awesome and a
crazy week and I could not do it without
you guys like huge thank you to
everybody who follow along on this
iPhone journey and adventure this past
week and I cannot wait because the
iPhone and the Apple watch it'll all be
here before we know it now that I'm back
I've had a little bit of time to
decompress and think about the event the
main highlights of course in case you
did miss it is they announced three new
iPhones there is the iPhone 11 which
comes in five different colors and the
iPhone pro in the iPhone chrome Mac's
the iPhone Pro comes in four colors now
a silver of gold and a Space Gray and
this new color which is a midnight green
and seeing the midnight green in person
was actually really cool because the
color that they showed during the
keynote it was kind of like a muted
color sort of washed out when you see it
in person every single time that I've
moved it around in different lighting it
always looks different and I really
actually like the color a lot although
for me personally even though it's not
Friday yet I haven't done my pre-orders
I think I'm gonna go with the silver
because I did order the white a ceramic
watch so I would like for my phone and
watch to match the main difference
between the iPhone 11pro and the regular
iPhone 11 is the cameras and the display
so the iPhone 11 has an LCD display
whereas the iPhone Pro has a super
Retina OLED XDR display there was some
crazy long-term that they call it it -
11 also only has two cameras only it's
like okay it only has two cameras it has
two cameras because the ten are still
only had one so this is an addition and
an upgrade the iPhone Pro has three
cameras it has an ultra wide a telephoto
and a wide-angle lens and the
facing does 4k it's also been bumped up
to 12 megapixels so you're definitely
getting better photos you're also able
to do slo-mo video front-facing and I do
shoot a lot of front-facing video when
I'm vlogging so the pros three cameras
are the ultra wide the wide and the
telephoto lens so being able to have
those three cameras gives you a lot more
flexibility when you're filming that's
cool because when you are filming you'll
still be able to see the outside frame
of whatever else would potentially be in
frame if you switched lenses so that's
something that a lot of these other
phones don't do they may have these
multiple cameras they're not really
using them all at the same time and that
brings us to filmic Pro I've used this
app before but it's kind of something
that really lets you take advantage of
your iPhone camera but this new version
of filmic Pro you are able to see all of
your cameras at the same time and this
is really cool because that's something
that I've never seen before and
something that I think is gonna be fun
for vloggers and content creators you'll
be able to film using two of those
angles at the same time so if I want to
film a front-facing but also a rear
facing camera at the same time you can
so I can't wait to try that out I'm not
sure when the release of the new filming
pro will be out but when it is I'll
definitely be doing some extensive
coverage of that the introduction of the
new ultra wide is something that is not
new that we've seen that in films before
and it isn't something that I've been
really wanting on the iPhone he also
talked about this new deep fusion
photography which is like a
computational math scientific mad
scientist I don't remember his exact
precise words so basically using AI to
generate a more detailed photos that
will be a software update later this
year
but I can probably sit here and talk for
the next like 5 hours about everything
that they just got it I just wanted to
do a quick little recap and this doesn't
seem to be so quick is it being able to
shoot when the ultra wide is gonna be so
fun for video and vlogging and doing
landscape photography so I cannot wait
to get my hands on this thing and really
test it out I think the big question for
a lot of people is do I need to spend
the extra money to get the pro or will I
be perfectly happy with the 11 do I need
to upgrade if I have a 10s do I need to
upgrade if I have a 10 I think really I
would just encourage you to go to the
Apple store if you are on the
and test it out the photos look
different than the film that you already
have is this something that is going to
make a huge difference in your life it's
something that you have the extra money
to spend if you are a content creator I
definitely think that it is something
that you should consider because a lot
of the stuff is investing in your future
in your career and in your content
creation they also announced a new iPad
which I tested out at the event and I
was playing Apple arcade on it and I'm
kind of really excited about Apple
arcade mostly because it is something
that you can play it Frost all platforms
you can play on your phone you can play
on your iPad you can play on Apple TV
you can play on your Mac like it's
really cool how this is all just
integrate it into the Apple ecosystem
it's also really cool because you can
use a controller yes a freaking Xbox
controller or a Playstation controller
on your Apple TV or on your Mac or on
your phone or your iPad that's something
that I never thought in a million years
would ever happen and when they
announced that at WWDC I was like yeah
that's cool Swapnil arcade is $4.99 and
also Apple TV plus is $4.99 I thought
that they would announce some sort of a
bundling service but I feel like maybe
later on down the line they will but
both of those prices was way less than I
thought it was gonna be but that also
could be is they want to keep those
costs a little bit lower because if you
do buy an iPad or an iPhone like you're
gonna want things to do on it so keeping
you in that ecosystem and keeping those
prices down I feel like more people
who've access to it and be willing to
spend those extra dollars but the good
news is they said that you will get a
year free when you buy a new iPhone or
an iPad or a Mac or anything like that
so that is a nice little added bonus it
also announced an Apple watch Series 5
which I was very excited I kinda didn't
think they were going to I'm not sure
why I thought they weren't but it
doesn't matter what I thought because
they did they announced a few different
new watch faces maybe new titanium and
also have brushed a black titanium they
have a new ceramic which is the one that
I ordered and
can't wait satis they have the cellular
and GPS in the aluminum versions they
have some Nike ones they have a new
Hermes black band which is so cool it
looks amazing but yeah I went back to
the ceramic I had this random ik years
ago and it still is just my favorite
look and especially if I get the silver
phone like they're gonna match perfectly
and I just I said I can't wait because I
well I guess I have to wait I don't have
a choice but either way it's gonna be
here so soon I would love to hear from
you guys though what did you think of
the event which phone was your favorite
are you going to upgrade are you not
gonna upgrade leave me all of those
comments below and I'll be chatting with
you guys in the comments so you've got
new phones on the way we've got new
watches we've got a new iPad we have
Apple TV we have apple arcade I'm trying
to think if there's anything that I'm
missing it probably should have took
some notes but I did it anyway we're
back on the white wall for iPhone season
I just wanted to kind of give it a nice
little throwback especially for the six
million sub milestone a lot of you guys
said you guys missed the white wall so I
thought let's bring it back for a bit
there will be plenty more iPhone and
Apple watch and Apple content coming up
this month so make sure you guys are
subscribed and I will see you soon
don't pop make sure you're following on
Twitter and Instagram to is if you're
not gonna be sad